after a year of insisting that the wuflu
had nothing
whatsoever to do with the wuhan
institute of virology
dr fauci is now changing his tune which
raises one question above all the others
how many more times does this guy need
to get caught
lying to the public before the people
wise up
speaking of flops lebron james teaches
us a lesson about race relations
rand paul teaches a lesson about
vaccines and teen vogue teaches young
girls
how to perform witchcraft with their
bodily fluids i'm michael and also the
michael knowles show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from friday is from
kanye ray jepsen one of the greatest
names
on youtube uh who says quote let me be
perfectly clear
i did not have any virological relations
with that lab
fauci 2022 it's increasingly sounding
like that
he is as credible as bill clinton in his
denials of
improper uh activity but fouchy finally
now is starting to
crack those lies up more and more and
more you know
the the way that we can know that fauci
is being dishonest right now is that we
can look back in time and see what he
was saying earlier
so when they contradict one another we
say well something went wrong here what
if you want to look back in time and you
want to preserve wonderful memories
of your family i would recommend
checking out legacy box
legacy box is an effortless way to have
your outdated media digitally preserved
in a modern format right now they're
offering you 40
off so that you can ensure that your
memories are safe
for generations i just came into a
treasure trove
of physical media pictures videotapes
and you know what they're fading
and they're getting harder and harder to
look at i'm so glad i found them i
thought i'd misplace them
i thought they were lost forever frankly
i've got photos
of my not just my grandparents my
great-grandparents
my great-great-grandparents and my
little kid
my four-month-old baby is going to be
able to see them
because i am digitally preserving them i
am making an investment in my
family it's the where it's the best
investment you can possibly make
particularly if you're
if you're a little more on the
conservative side you want to conserve
these wonderful rich memories it's just
wonderful i can't possibly recommend it
enough best part is you send in your
physical media
you get all that physical media back but
you also get a digitally preserved copy
right now legacy box is offering 40
off so your family can celebrate
meaningful moments at a fraction of the
normal price go to legacy box dot com
slash knowles to get started
legacybox.com and all you get forty four
zero percent off
legacy box dot com slash knowles i
am willing to go out on a limb for 2024
right now
i know there are a lot of candidates in
the race and they're going to be
governors and senators and maybe trump
will run again
i will endorse any 2024
candidate who promises to banish dr
fauci to saint helena
i don't want them to banish him to elba
he might escape elba i want them to
banish him to saint helena
i want him to be canceled i'm pro-cancel
culture now let's do it
if cancel culture means getting rid of
dr fauci and ostracizing him to the
other side of the world
find by me this freaking
guy just lie
after lie after misdirection
after dishonesty after admission to his
own deception
after lie dr fauci
was asked a simple question it's a
question he's been asked multiple times
but he gave a different answer this time
he said
that he is here's the question are you
are you convinced that the
wuhan virus originated in nature without
any kind of manipulation in a lab no i'm
not convinced
about that i think that we should
continue to investigate
what went on in china until we find out
to the best of our ability
exactly what happened certainly the
people who've investigated say
it likely was the emergence from an
animal reservoir
that then infected individuals but it
could have been something else
and we need to find that out so you know
that's the reason why i said i'm
perfectly
in favor of any investigation that looks
into the origin
of the virus oh wow dr fauci sounded
pretty open-minded now isn't look no i
never said
look why would you stupid sheep ever
accuse me
of saying that the virus didn't come
from a lab
uh well because for a year
you dismissed the suggestion that the
virus that was discovered 400 yards from
the wuhan institute of virology where
they were studying these viruses
that maybe the lab had something to do
with that you dismissed it out of hand
you rejected it
for a year in case you forgot a group of
highly qualified evolutionary
virologists
looked at the sequences there and the
sequences
in uh bats
as they evolve and the mutations that it
took to get to the point where it is now
is totally consistent with a jump
of a species from an animal to a human
so
i mean the the paper will be available i
i don't have the authors right now but
we can make that available too
that wasn't it that's not all so he said
look
totally consistent there's no evidence
about that but then he does an interview
with
national geographic he says quote
man this show's going to really hurt my
voice today if i got to keep quoting
this jerk dr
fauci if you look at the evolution of
the virus in bats
and what's out there now the scientific
evidence is
very very strongly leaning toward
this could not have been artificially or
deliberately manipulated everything
about the stepwise evolution
over time strongly indicates
that this virus evolved in nature
and then jumped species though she says
this is directly quoting from national
geographic
based on the scientific evidence he also
doesn't
entertain an alternate theory that
someone found the coronavirus in the
wild
brought it into a lab and then it
accidentally escaped
so explicitly in a wide ranging
interview says fauci does
not enter even entertain this theory cbs
follows up says
when asked if there could have been not
even if there was just
there could have been a scenario where
scientists found the virus
outside the lab brought it back and then
it escaped fauchi
shut the line of questioning down quote
but that means it was in the wild to
begin with
that's why i don't get why that what
they're talking about
and why i don't spend a lot of time
going in
on this circular argument he said
but now now he's in on it now he's
he's opening his mind because if you
were listening to this show a year ago
if you were listening to verdict with
senator cruz
a show that i co-host a year ago you
would have heard
me just just talking about the
probability
that if you find a coronavirus having to
do with bats
400 yards from a virology institute that
was
working on these very viruses that maybe
that's a little too much of a
coincidence
maybe the one had to do with the other
now
i'm not a virologist i'm not the head of
one of these nih departments like fauci
has been for half a century
how is it that i in my untutored
ignorance
was able to put two and two together but
dr fatchi was not
is it because dr fauci is an idiot i
don't think dr fatchi's an idiot i think
he's probably
very intelligent is it because dr fauci
was lying to us well he's lied to us
before and admitted that he lied to us
before
notably about the masks the efficacy of
masks where he said at the very
beginning he said
do not wear masks they do not work then
five seconds later he said
yeah you have to wear the mask and when
asked why he changed his views what did
he say
he said well at the time i feared that
all you idiot she i'm paraphrasing but
not by much
all you idiot sheep would go out and buy
up all the masks and then the nurses
wouldn't have enough masks so i lied to
you
and then later on when i realized there
were enough masks i told you what i
believe to be the truth
and frankly i don't even i don't even
exactly agree with dr fauci's
conclusions here but regardless
he the man doesn't have credibility so i
think it's the latter is he an idiot or
a liar i don't think he's an idiot
so if there's no evidence that he's an
idiot and there's
we know that he's a liar then in this
case it would seem to be
the easier explanation why is he
admitting it now
because he's finally had a change of
heart and he's going to tell us the
truth no
it's because he can't hide it any longer
why can't he hide it because
three researchers from the wuhan
institute of virology
which is china's only biosafety level 4
laboratory
were hospitalized with the coronavirus
with coronavirus-like symptoms i guess
the test didn't exist yet
not in february not in january
2020 not even in december of 2019 but in
november
of 2019 months before we were told that
this thing appeared
now is this because these multiple
researchers at the wuhan institute of
virology just
all happen to walk down to the same wet
market
i i don't think so something tells me
that these
chinese government scientists are not go
going to get their lunch at the wet
market down the street
it was obviously in the lab
so this has escaped they can't cover
this up anymore this information has
gotten out so now all of a sudden dr
fauci is a little more open-minded
david asher who's the state department's
former lead investigator
oversaw the task force into the covet 19
virus and its origin
says quote he is very doubtful that
three people in highly protected
circumstances who are all working on
coronaviruses
all became sick with covid-like symptoms
enough so that they were hospitalized
in quote severe conditions all in the
same week and it didn't have
anything to do with the coronavirus
obviously
obviously so now
we've we've pushed fauci's hand right or
or the leaks from the chinese government
or the state department or wherever they
came from
have have forced fauci's hand and now he
says all right maybe it was the lab
whatever sheep you can't remember and no
one's going to cover this on the
mainstream media you're not going to see
this on cbs and nbc
no one's going to no one's no one's
asked any questions of fouchy thus far
in the mainstream media
the establishment media it's only the
alternative media
shows like this but you know when when
we mentioned this including senator cruz
when when we were discussing the
likelihood that this virus came from the
lab
we were called conspiracy theorists
radicals crazies kooks tin foil hat
listen to the science listen to dr
fatchi well now fauci's admitting that
we're very
possibly right what more
what more do you need to ditch this
jerk dr fauci speaking of flops
lebron james he is apparently a
professional athlete
he's he's a full-time leftist political
activist but i guess he plays a
some sport as well he was uh recently in
in hot water on social media because
lebron james as you might know uh is one
one prone to exaggerating his injuries
so he was sort of i guess kind of felt
and anyway
he uh some guy barely like breathes on
him and he flops over and he's writhing
on the floor and he's in
in immense pain
oh there we go oh my gosh oh he broke
his arm or his
neck probably too and oh gosh look at
him oh no
so now they're all fighting on the court
okay very very very silly stuff so very
so there was another one of these
that happened uh was it last week yeah
another
another one here we go someone barely
breathes on lebron james
and then up there oh no he's scared he
almost did a somersault
oh he's down look at it so anderson will
shoot two free from
not no lebron james is a very big
muscular guy and he
he's sort of known for doing this the
reason i bring it up is not because i
care about lebron james or
basketball or sports really generally
it's because this is our whole culture
we are living
in the flop culture where everybody it
needs to pretend
like every little possible perceived
maybe microaggression is going to knock
them on the floor and they're all going
to arrive
in pain that's very embarrassing it's
very humiliating sort of like when you
go into the brick and mortar auto parts
store and they don't have your part and
they ask you a lot of questions
that's why you got to check out
rockauto.com oh hey there mr brick and
mortar auto parts store
um my car is broken oh yeah michael well
is it a gqt
or a 7xv i don't i don't know oh yeah do
you need the
hklp pump or the i don't know exactly
well
yeah do they go in the back what do they
do they look they don't have the part
they go online they probably go to
rockholder.com they order the same part
they charge you twice as much don't do
that don't subject yourself to that
it's humiliating go to rockauto.com it's
a family come on man i sound like the
president
come on man hey just go it's a family
business serving auto parts customers
online for 20 years go to rockauto.com
to shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers the catalog is
unique remarkably easy to navigate so
simple
that even i can do it prices are always
fair it's not gimmicky it's not going to
go up and down every two hours
head on over there right now
rockauto.com you'll see all the parts
available for your car or truck
then write knowles k-n-w-l-e-s in there
how did you hear about us box
so they know that we sent you a lot of
people are making fun of lebron james
because he flops and he rides and he
cries
and he lays very performative in in
his uh grief and grievance
but it's not just on the court he does
that
politically as well lebron james came
out and said that black men cannot walk
out the door
in this country without being hunted
down by racist whites do you remember
that
that is very humiliating for him he
should be ashamed it's
womanish behavior not womanly it's
womanly is good when a woman behaves
like a woman when a man behaves like a
woman
that's womanish it's it's a very
pathetic sort of behavior
but lebron does it because our culture
no longer rewards
forbearance patience grit
courage manlyness we don't we don't
reward that
we reward whining and crying and
complaining
and pouting and grievance that's what we
reward now so
you're going to get more of that that's
that's how incentives work right
all we hear and specifically i guess in
the case of lebron james
all we hear is how
racist and by racist we mean anti-black
this country is it's racist it's in our
core it's in our dna
all the way up to the presidency joe
biden just last week
whining and complaining about the
horrible pervasive
racism every time
we're silent every time
we let hate flourish we make a lie
of who we are as a nation i mean it
literally
we cannot let the very foundation
of this country continue to be eaten
away
like it has been in other moments in our
history and happening again
i looked at this law you all passed as
maybe the first
break the first significant break
on a moment in our history that has to
be turned around
not democratic has to be turned around
has to be turned around the racism
that's eating away at the foundation of
our country but also racism
is the foundation of our country because
of the it's the 1619 project country
and it's the original sin and so we're
very racist but we can't let racism eat
away our racist country it doesn't
so so hollow it's so
shallow it's so meaningless this
nonsense that he's spouting
joe biden has never had a whole lot
going on between the ears
it's not just senility that is causing
this kind of
nonsense to spew out of his mouth this
has been true since the 70s since he got
into politics
but it it's it's become
so tired it's become so tedious
i was having a drink with a dearly
beloved
liberal relative of mine and she brought
up
the alleged systemic anti-black
racism specifically in policing the
police brutality and she said michael
how can you be so complacent about
criminal justice reform
bla black men are being slaughtered by
the police innocent black men being
shot down by the police all the time
it's happening constantly in this
country
we need to stop that epidemic of
innocent black guys being killed by the
police
i pointed out to her there isn't one
there is no epidemic of that it isn't
happening
just look at the numbers that washington
post keeps a database of fatal police
shootings
as of june 22 2020
how many unarmed black men were killed
by the police by the way unarmed does
not mean that shooting is not justified
does not necessarily mean there are
plenty of times when people are unarmed
where the shooting
would still be justified but
let's just go with that number unarmed
how many
as of june 22 2020 in 2019 how many
14 not 14 000 not 1400 not 140 was 14
unarmed black men
killed by the police compared to 25
unarmed white guys killed by the police
in 2019.
just and i mentioned this to her and she
said well well then how come we see
all these shootings and i said because
the media have an interest
in racial division and ginning up racial
tensions and so they broadcast every
single one and they don't broadcast any
of the times that the white guys are
shot
that's why it's very simple it's just
propaganda
consider the hate crimes the white
supremacy anti-black country where
in the words of ton easy coats that
extraordinarily overrated
pro stylist that the black bodies are
disrespected whatever
whatever nonsense doj hate crime
statistics if you were if you were to
guess
what the hate crime statistics look like
you know the offenders
you would guess i think listening to joe
biden listening to cnn listening to the
mainstream
left leftist media that hate crimes in
this country are when
ku klux klan members you know neo-nazis
are out there
hunting down innocent black people which
is pervasive and it happens a lot that's
what you would think of when you would
think of a hate crime right
which is even the designation hate crime
is preposterous
because it it juxtaposes itself i
suppose with love crimes or something
like that but they're not you know if
you're
if you go and you harm somebody there i
think that implies a certain
level of hatred according to the doj
hate crime statistics for 2019
the percentage of offenders who
committed hate crimes
who were white and that includes
hispanics so the the statistics now
designate hispanics as white much of the
time
52.5 52.5
of the time the offenders were white or
hispanic
23.9 percent of the time they were black
the rest of the time the race is unknown
how does that compare to the american
population in america
73 percent of people are white or
hispanic
designated as white and 13.4 percent
are black which means
that hate crimes are much more likely to
be committed
by black people than white people
now i'm not saying there's it's it's a
biological
it's just something in the dna i'm not
saying that there might be many many
reasons why
that is the case but what is certainly
not the case
is that there is an epidemic of white
supremacist anti-black
it just it just doesn't exist
actually the likelihood is quite the
opposite of what we're being told by the
media it's just
propaganda and the only kind of racism
that is permitted in this country that
is
not only tolerated but actively
encouraged is
to some degree racial discrimination
against asians
and to a larger degree against whites
and you see it of course in affirmative
action in the
policies at universities and the
policies in hiring and there are plenty
of people who will say well we need to
do that to address historical wrongs
okay fine
whatever whatever your argument is
whatever your justification is
let's put that aside for a second at
least acknowledge that the only
legal racism in this country that is
actively encouraged by our culture a
culture that says we need to abolish
whiteness for goodness sakes is
not the kind of racism that everyone's
always bloviating about
tulsi gabbard a sort of democrat i don't
know is she still a democrat i guess she
is
tulsi gabbard pointed this out the other
day when the mayor of chicago lori
lightfoot came out
and said that she's only going to give
interviews to black journalists
only one-on-one interviews to black and
brown journalists
you think uh what huh you can't do that
well tulsi tweets out quote
mayor lightfoot's blatant anti-white
racism is abhorrent i call upon
president biden
kamala harris and other leaders of our
country of all races to join me in
calling for mayor lightfoot's
resignation
our leaders must condemn all racism
including anti-white
oh my goodness the pushback she got
you're not allowed to say that
because what what the radical left says
is you can't you can't be racist against
white people
and i suppose they would make the same
argument about asians but that's a
little
tricky for them to make right now so
they mostly just talk about the white
people so you can't be
racist against white people because they
redefine racism as they always do you
know
the left wields power in many ways by
redefining the words if you control the
words you control the culture which is
by the way the subtitle of my upcoming
book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
available now of course for pre-order
hello do we uh where's that do we get a
ding
there we go okay good good i just want
to make sure that that bell
comes up so kamala hara says look
anti-white racism is a big problem
too yes of course it is but they say
that racism is sort of discrimination
and the judgment
plus power and they define the power
as being whiteness they say that we're
in white supremacy right they just begin
it's
so talk about circular arguments getting
back to dr fauci
they say it's ju therefore it's just not
possible it only runs in one direction
that's just a standard that's just their
their standard that they're going to
enforce
and it's a racial hierarchy and it's a
caste system you're seeing this play out
not just in the
traditional racial division that
radicals try to gin up in this country
namely the division between
blacks and whites you're seeing it also
now specifically
in this israel issue so there's
looks like things are calming down over
there in israel but
this flare-up was notable
in that you had a real party-line
division here
the left the democrats supported the
palestinian arabs won against israel
the conservatives and the republicans
generally supported israel and that was
the dividing line
why is that it's because of the exact
same
vision it's the the exact same racial
political
ideology if you'd rather see
candace owens in real life rather than
just trending on twitter as she often
does
today very well might be your lucky day
if you sign up
as a daily wire member with code vip
you'll get 20
off your new membership you will be
automatically entered for a chance to
win a trip to the daily wire studios to
see candace
live not only will you be meeting
candace but you will be getting an
inside look at her studio
our office and front row seats to watch
her live and in action on her talk show
candace go enter to win a candace vip
pass right now at dailywire.com
subscribe using code vip for 20 off
every day on my show
i talk about a lot of great products and
services from sponsors that i love and i
use
we want to get to know you better so we
can choose our sponsors with you in mind
go to dailywire.com
fill out my audience survey tell us a
little more about yourself to sweeten
the whole thing
you will be entered to win a thousand
dollar gift card you can only take the
survey once so to increase your chances
of winning
do the same thing at ben's show drew
show matt walsh's show
and you get their surveys as well mine
is dailywire.com we'll be right back
with a lot more
the same racial propaganda that you're
seeing in the united states broadly
you're also seeing applied to this
israel israel-palestinian conflict so in
the united states we're told
that there is an epidemic of
white supremacist anti-black racism and
hate crimes and this and that and the
other thing and you look into the actual
data here and you say
actually i think the situation might be
a bit different than we're told in the
mainstream media but a lot of people
believe it because that's where they get
their information
same thing going on here in israel so
there's this guy luca robert lewis
he is a pro soccer goalie
who was accosted by pro-palestinian
thugs i guess i'm using pro here in
different ways
one i mean professional the other i
guess these guys were professional
palestinian thugs
but they are really they support the
palestinian cause so he's a 20 year old
guy he's on
oh my gosh new york has a soccer team so
much for the country
uh anyway he said that on thursday night
he was accosted by a group of six to
eight
palestinian men who accosted him asked
if he was jewish
and then brandished knives and he said
that
when he said that he was not jewish one
of the men said good
but then lewis responded and said what
if i was jewish and the man got in his
face and said
i'll beat the effing s out of you and
kill you
a lot of stories like this now this is
now what we're told is
that the evil jews in israel are bombing
the poor innocent
hamas terrorists and we've got to feel
really bad about this
and this is an atrocity and we've got to
condemn
israel and we've got to support the
palestinian arabs and that's what
we're it's apartheid human rights or
whatever
okay but then you look into the actual
situation it looks a little bit
different doesn't it
we're told that
this sort of event that the soccer
player is describing does not happen
but you're hearing it a lot drew clavin
was at dinner the other night in
l.a right before he left la and like two
blocks down the road
same thing happened a group of
pro-palestinian guys bust into the
restaurant and they say is anyone in
here jewish
guy says he is and they beat him up
well what what happened to the poor
innocent
palestinians and the evil awful
bellicose jews
that seems to be contradicted that
narrative doesn't seem to be playing out
where's the real dividing line here it's
seemed to be
pretty ideological you know in the past
both parties were very pro-israel or
sort of reflexively pro-israel just like
it's bring up israel they'd say
america's greatest ally ever you know we
need to increase foreign aid or
something right
and there were some criticisms of this
levied on both sides of the aisle
now however the left has really become
the anti-israel party and the right
is the pro-israel party and it really is
just about that clear bernie sanders
just came out he was on cbs face the
nation
he condemned the israeli government and
said that it contains overt
racists well what you have got to do is
also
understand that over the years the
netanyahu government has become
extremely right-wing and that there are
people
in the israeli government now who are
overt
racists you have in west uh jerusalem
people being evicted from their homes
tremendous pressure
on people within israel the arab
community
as well as gaza so you have a very
difficult situation
you have hamas a terrorist group you
have a right-wing israeli government
and the situation is getting worse and
all that i'm saying
is that the united states of america has
got to be leading the world
in bringing people together not simply
supplying weapons
to kill children in gaza so that's what
that's what the israelis are doing
they're killing children that's what
they do and we've got to stop them from
doing that
those poor innocent hamas run
palestinians
a lot of people are going to watch this
and say wait a second bernie's a jew
how bernie's a jew but he's very
anti-israel
right it shows you that the extreme
right
and the extreme left are wrong about the
jews
you'll notice there's a strange
everybody hates the jews
historically right there's karl marx
hates the jews hitler hates the jews
all these you'll see the extreme leftist
radicals they're very
anti-israel and frankly i think
anti-jewish and the very very extreme
right you'll you'll see a lot of that as
well
because they think that the jews are
monolithic in their
politics in their culture that's really
not the case
i think the breakdown is not ethnic
with regard to judaism i i suspect it's
more religious
and this is borne out by a lot of public
surveys
secular jews jews who don't practice the
religion
other than you know maybe they make
latkes once a year or something
they are moving much more left-wing
they are moving and the left is moving
much more anti-israel and this is
happening at the same time
orthodox jews jews who practice the
religion
are moving much more right-wing
they're in the american context they're
much more likely now to vote for
republicans than they have been in the
past
and the opposite could be said on the
secular side much more likely to vote
for democrats
that's a religious question it's just
hard for people to recognize this now
because of this strain of materialism
that comes through all the time the the
constant materialism
of of certainly the extreme left but
even of the the right a little bit as
well
you'll notice that the the fringiest
characters who are the most
likely to engage in sort of racial
identity politics on the on the right
tend to be atheists or at the very least
uh irreligious they tend not to be
christian
that's that's the way it goes but if you
recognize that there's a spiritual
component here and that the mind matters
and the soul matters
then these things become a little bit
more complicated
speaking of unusual religions teen vogue
teen vogue is teaching young girls
how to perform witchcraft with their
bodily fluid i'm not this is not i know
it sounds like a joke like i'm
this is real the headline from teen
vogue this is a magazine aimed at
i guess 12 to 17 year old girls i think
is the target demo
headline menstrual blood magic three
spells for your period
how to make menstruation magical
always remember that magic is for
believers but this column can also
simply serve as a guide to getting in
touch with yourself magically or not
so it's not just purely metaphorical
here they're talking about
actual witchcraft
rather than play into this patriarchal
shame
of the stigma of menstruation quote
witches
and other masters of magic believe
menstruation
is a gift from nature
and then it goes on and it's talking
about owning our power protecting
unwanted negativity energetic fields
healing chakras by becoming one with our
own body
they're actually serious about this
stuff
i think i know this is going to sound
radical to some people on
the right who are who are free speech
absolutists
i think this sort of thing ought to be
discouraged
i don't think our our founding fathers
would have considered this you know
instructing 13 year old girls
in menstrual witchcraft i don't think
they would have considered that
the purpose of the first amendment i
think they probably would have
considered this obscene
prurient content i'm not sure
that this is exactly a blessing of
liberty please pardon
to the squishy conservatives who support
drag queen story hour too
we should discourage this kind of thing
a lot of people say that we need to
permit all kind literally all kinds of
speech and behavior or virtual
almost all kinds of speech and behavior
because otherwise
what's there are otherwise we're going
to end up with the salem witch trials
basically we're gonna these women we're
gonna for things they've said and done
and we don't even know we're gonna
persecute them for that these are
literal witches
you know the the problem with the salem
witch trials
is uh presumably some of these women
were not witches you know
but what if the is in the argument like
there's no such thing as witches well i
don't know these people seem to think
they're a lot they're witches
so i suppose a witch trial is
appropriate
goodness gracious me i'm reminded always
when these sorts of crazy things come up
of uh i think my single favorite quote
in all of politics
churchill reagan lincoln pericles
all pale in comparison to one quote from
from pat robertson
in 92 i think it was and he said quote
the feminist agenda is not about equal
rights for women
it is about a socialist anti-family
political movement
that encourages women to leave their
husbands kill their children
practice witchcraft destroy capitalism
and become lesbians
and so everyone laughs at this quote you
know pat you crazy pat robertson what
are you oh my gosh here's the proof
this is like now whenever we read a
story about how the frickin frogs
actually are turning gay
and we say oh my gosh alex jones was
right well i read this teen vogue
article and i say oh my gosh
pat robertson we should have listened if
only we had listened
29 years ago perhaps we could have
avoided this speaking of weird
sex stuff this is a story it's actually
a week or two old at this point but i
don't want to skip over it i think
basically the entire liberal
establishment wants us to skip over this
story but i'm not going to
there's a report out being being
reported in many
mainstream publications
that bill gates was very very close to
jeffrey epstein
and that his close relationship with
jeffrey epstein was one of the reasons
for the
divorce that we're seeing now between
melinda and bill
previously bill gates has said no i
barely knew epstein we had very little
to do with one another ah yeah maybe met
once or twice well now we're seeing
gates visited epstein a bunch of times
many many times
and even flew on the lolita express on
epstein's private plane
according to reports from anonymous bill
and melinda gates foundation sources
uh the real reason that bill gates was
sucking up to epstein was not for the
fancy and prurient massages from the
underage girls
but it was to leverage epstein's
connections to win the nobel peace prize
because remember epstein was a big
character
in the philanthropy business this is why
everyone's so shocked to see
photos of epstein with trump or photos
of epstein with clinton or now with
clinton you know it seems they traveled
together a bit
their relationship might have been a
little deeper but even you see a photo
with him and trump don't forget
that epstein was a pretty prominent guy
and he was
ostensibly a billionaire and he
was able to you know he had
placed his name for him at harvard he
was giving big donations and sort of
things like that
i i believe this i bet bill gates
probably does want the nobel prize what
else is he going to do at this point in
his life he's
done a lot of things and so he's been
aiming a lot of his activities
at that sort of thing was he getting up
to no good
at epstein's condo yeah or you know his
townhouse yeah maybe maybe he was
the the reason i bring this up too is
melinda gates's oppo research team and
public relations strategy
is second to none absolutely second to
none
it would seem pretty clear to me that
this is coming from the melinda camp of
things and the way
that these stories are coming out it's
not an accident it's not like oh now the
intrepid journalists are doing their job
we've known about the bill gates jeffrey
epstein connection
for years no one's said boo about it no
one's asked a question practically
but now that melinda gates and bill are
splitting up
you're seeing this drip drip
drip it's a pretty effective strategy
and
it's something you need to be aware of
when you're when you're hearing about
whatever any kind of story for the first
question you should ask when you're
hearing about a story is why am i
hearing about this where did the story
come from and why are the media
reporting it
because stories don't make it through
the news accidentally
there are editors who vet stories who
choose which stories to push you choose
when to push them
that's the sort of question we need to
be asking and very often people will
drip stories
to distract from other things it
actually brings me to a very unpopular
opinion i have but i have to mention it
everyone's gone ufo crazy right now for
summary all of a sudden now
everyone's talking about ufos and it's
all the government leaks that are doing
it oh yes the pentagon is going to
release a ufo report and
all these pentagon officials are now
just coincidentally talking about ufos
they call them now uaps
to the press and i wonder why that is
why is that
it's very sensationalist is it because
some new information's come out no we've
known about these sorts of incidents for
for years and decades why is this being
leaked now
especially from the military which is
usually pretty rigid
on leaks what's the strategy here i have
a very unpopular opinion
i don't think there is any reason to
believe whatsoever
that there is any life anywhere in the
universe outside of our little rock
the third rock from the sun i know we're
told
oh no there must be michael here's the
argument the argument is
michael the universe is big it's so big
so look it's just a matter of
probability michael that there's
life elsewhere in the universe maybe not
intelligent but there's got to be life
why why is that probable we we don't
know
anything scientifically about the origin
of life we don't know anything
anybody who tells you they do know
something is making it up because we
don't know
maybe we know how the bird on this one
island got a little bit of a bigger beak
but we don't know how you go from not
life to life we just have no idea
scientifically the best theory we have
right now is that god made adam out of
clay i'm not i'm not joking about that
we don't there is no
more proven comprehensive scientific
theory about how you go from no life to
life
so i just find it very strange when
people talk about the problem but look
it's big
it's a big place and so the probability
is there's life elsewhere
in order to ascertain a probability you
need to know
literally anything about the topic
you're talking about but we don't
and so i'm not saying there is
definitively there is no life anywhere
else in the universe
i'm just saying there is no reason to
believe that there is
and furthermore in the political
question of why are all these ufo leaks
coming out right now
i have no reason to believe that the
narrative were being fed
is above board or is is to be taken in
earnest
rather than perhaps as a way to not be
talking about
other stories
you know bill gates this
derelict has made himself the number one
vaccine expert in the country you i love
how whenever a conservative goes out
there and questions dr fauci
which is tricky to do because dr fauci
holds conflicting views on virtually
everything
he's contradicted himself on all the big
questions but if you go out and you
question whatever fouchy's view is
today you're told well you don't you're
not an expert you're not an
epidemiologist
you don't know anything about vaccines
you say
i have the same epidemiological degree
that bill gates has and bill gates is
going on tv all the time talking about
this so why
why are you listening to him well rand
paul is not going to be listening to him
senator rand paul
let me correct that dr rand paul who is
a u.s senator
came out and he said he doesn't plan to
get the vaccine
i think that we should have a choice
whether we take a vaccine or not because
frankly all the studies show that i have
just as good of immunity
as the people have been vaccinated now
in a year's time if people say oh
people that had it naturally are getting
infected a lot more than people have
been vaccinated
i might change my mind but until they
show me evidence
that people have already had the
infection are dying in large numbers or
being hospitalized or getting very sick
i've just made my own personal decision
that i'm not getting vaccinated because
i've already had the disease and i have
natural immunity now
um but that should be my you know in a
free country you would think people
would honor you know the idea that each
individual would get to make their
medical decisions that it wouldn't be
big brother coming and telling me
you know what i have to do are they
going to also tell me i can't have a
cheeseburger for lunch or they're going
to tell me i have to eat carrots only
and you know cut my calories all that
was probably good for me but i don't
think
big brother ought to tell me to do it oh
outrageous
outra anti-science
evil crazy
he's saying that just because he has
natural immunity he's not going to get
the vaccine that was hastily developed
just because he already very likely has
natural immunity because he already had
the virus can you believe that
huh no wonder he was trending on twitter
he was after rand paul said that
sorry let me correct that after dr rand
paul who's a u.s senator said that
yeah there was a twitter moment so this
is not just again that
not just a totally natural trend this
was curators of twitter
putting his name up there and then
writing a little description beneath it
and the description that twitter wrote
was quote contrary to the advice of
medical
and scientific professionals senator
rand paul says he is not getting
vaccinated
because he already contracted covet 19.
you see the problem there do you see
you see the weird thing about that
twitter moment
contrary to the advice of medical and
scientific professionals
senator oh they should have corrected it
dr rand paul
he is a medical and scientific
professional and by the way he's a
fairly serious one
so rand paul he's not an epidemiologist
but you know
epidemiology is a it's a
suspect field okay it's not a because
it's
social science there's a sort of
hard science component to it but then
it's a broader social scientific field
as well
rand paul is an ophthalmologist he's an
eye doctor
and you might say well michael that's
totally different than the study of
viruses
ophthalmology is one of the most
difficult fields of medical science
when people are going through med school
the really really smart ones who are
really really talented
end up in i don't know three or four
disciplines
one of which is ophthalmology it's very
hard to be an ophthalmologist
so rand paul who is no slouch in the
medical science department comes out and
he says
that he's not going to get it for this
perfectly rational reason and then
some 24 year old
ivy league graduate probably you know
who's spent most of
her career in college reading ibram
candy or some or angela davis
or something is coming out and
questioning rand paul's medical and
scientific expertise
because he's contradicting dr fauci who
is primarily not a scientist but a
politician
kind of backwards isn't it fortunately
americans are beginning to lose faith
in these politicians who are going
around wearing lab coats as the white
cassocks of their high church of secular
progressivism
americans are losing faith in dr fauci
specifically
according to a recent poll this poll
just came out from the trafalgar group
the number of americans who trust dr
fauci has dropped
extremely sharply over the past year of
those
asked whether their confidence had gone
up or down 42.2 percent surveyed said
they experienced
a decrease in their trust of
fouchy of that segment 12.1 said that
their confidence
it was just a decrease and 30.1 percent
said that their trust
had decreased significantly of course it
did
he lied to people
he lie you know there are many instances
where i think you you should
be a little cautious and say well he
misled well he changed his views
in a kind of convenient way that didn't
seem totally above board
but at least on that mask issue
it's just a lie right he said the masks
he said
it is my view that the masks don't work
sheep
you stupid idiot sheep again
paraphrasing only slightly
and then he came out and said no then of
course the masks work but there was
i was in fear that there would be a
shortage so i
told you that i didn't think the masks
work even when i did think the masks
work but now
i'm willing to tell you my true belief
which is that the masks work
that that's just a lie i mean that's
just outright deception
so when people no longer trust the
experts
that's not our fault it's not on us man
that's just
rational that's just reasonable that's
on
the fouches of the world meanwhile
you've got people like gretchen whitmer
gretchen whitmer the embattled governor
of michigan
democrat who hit the bar this weekend
and violated her own
covid lockdown orders in
gretchen whitmer's order said large
groups are not allowed to go to bars
unmasked hanging out
and yet there's a photo of her with a
bunch of her friends and he was 13
people
in total including her appointed chief
operations officer
who visited the land shark in east
lansing violating the restaurant orders
according to a photo that we're seeing
with our own eyes so we just look at
these people
and we say you don't believe it you
don't believe it
fauci doesn't believe it fauci wears a
mask in the middle of a baseball diamond
to dribble a pitch to home plate not
even he's dribbled it down the first
base line
and then that's when the cameras are on
but then when he's sitting next to
people who aren't even in his household
he's got the mask off and he's not even
eating or drinking
so we say yeah we don't we don't believe
you guys it's a big
flop it's a big flip-flop they're the
ones doing it it's a it's a show it's a
performance it
it really would make lebron james look
muted and modest in his performance and
i just
don't think we should buy it anymore i'm
michael knows this the michael knowles
show
stop buying it folks don't wear the mask
sheep is that what fauchies say that i
don't know he said it's very confusing
when i do that voice i'll see you
tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nikka geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the matt
well show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you your
family our country not just politics but
culture
faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show